[Musique]
joli
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo de
la société chaîne de sciences sociales
avec un petit peu de géographie
d'ailleurs j'ai mis ma patte montrent la
base sur l'étagère c'est une vidéo de
géographie tout de suite sans plus
attendre le générique génériques alors
aujourd'hui je voudrais vraiment vous
parler d'une chose pour le cours de
géographie c'est la démarche géographie
les élèves qui suivent le cours de
sciences sociales connaissent la
démarche et sciences sociales
mais souvent les élèves qui suivent le
cours de géographie ne connaissent pas
la démarche de géographie cette vidéo
s'adresse donc aux élèves qui suivent le
cours de géographie et aux nombreux
puisque en fédération wallonie bruxelles
tout le monde a droit à deux heures de
géographie maintenant ou très bientôt
et donc c'est très chouette et donc je
vous propose finalement de faire un
petit peu un focus sur ce qui est dans
ce programme le nouveau programme de
géographie
alors je sais bien qu'il ya des gens qui
sont pas très content qu'ils aient un
nouveau programme moi je trouve que
c'est assez chouette alors petite
remarque je ne prétends pas connaître
l'ensemble du programme
évidemment j'ai pas la science infuse
c'est pas moi qui écris le programme
figurez-vous que tu m'aimes pas jéhovah
mais voilà je pense que maintenant j'ai
acquis un certain degré pratique qui
fait que je commence à voir c'est quoi
la démarche géographique mais
certainement que des géographes vont
trouver très imprécis tout ce que je
vais dire dans cette vidéo je m'en
excuse
l'idée c'est juste de permettre à mes
élèves et éventuellement aux gens qui
suit cette chaîne que mieux comprendre
ce qu'est la démarche jeu dans les
commentaires sur youtube sont là pour
évidemment précisé
recadrés exprimer votre désaccord avec
ce que je pourrais dire dans cette vidéo
alors la démarche géographique
finalement ça s'intéressent à quoi ça
s'intéressent à un objet chaque sillans
à son objet alors pour la biologie bel
objet c'est le fonctionnement du vivant
et sciences sociales ce sont les faits
sociaux et en géographie c'est quoi
c'est l'ensemble des phénomènes qui sont
liées à l'espace à la surface de la
terre
on va s'intéresser à différents
phénomènes les fumées
à thouars les flux de marchandises
l'aménagement du territoire les
répartitions de population les
différents modes de production agricole
la répartition des différentes religions
tout ça finalement ce sont des
répartition spatiale que l'on va étudier
la première étape de la démarche
géographique c'est donc de décrire des
répartition spatiale et donc on va
décrire ces répartitions avec des
références spatiale des repères
géographiques qui vont nous permettre de
préciser avec des mots finalement
quelque chose qui est très visuel
évidemment on peut directement retour et
sur une carte ces répartitions donc
première étape de jeu des cris ou où se
trouve le phénomène que j'entends et
évidemment cette description va se faire
à plusieurs échelles
je vais le faire à une échelle très
petit l'échelle mondiale et je peux
aller une échelle très très très grande
échelle locale et donc entre ces deux
échelles je veux vraiment une infinité
des chaînes différentes que je pourrai
mobiliser ou pas en fonction de mon
niveau mais aussi en fonction de l'objet
que je vais étudier phénomène que je
vais études c'est vraiment
l'articulation entre différentes
échelles qui me permettent de bien
décrire et de bien circonscrire un
phénomène deuxième étape
je vais finalement allé voir dans
d'autres domaines
quels sont les corrélations qui sont
possibles entre le phénomène que je
viens de décrire et d'autres répartition
donc si dans l'état pages décrit les
répartitions de population jeu peut
m'intéresser dans l'étape 2 avoir tiens
qu'est ce qui correspond et je vais me
rendre compte que les populations font
généralement dans des plaines
généralement donc c'est vraiment ça
l'étape 2 c'est de faire des liens entre
une répartition spatiale que je veux
étudier que je vais analyser et
géographiquement et d'autres répartition
de différentes composantes au cours de
géographie tel que je le donne on
retient cinq composantes mais c'est un
découpage tout à fait arbitraire ou pour
beaucoup plus ou beaucoup moins toujours
les mêmes comme ça les élèves savent
bien quand il faut chercher des cartes
pour expliquer un phénomène
eh bien on va voir dans ces cinq
composantes là on se pose des questions
par rapport à ces cinq composantes
ces cinq composantes ce sont les
suivantes la composante naturelle
la composante démographique la
composante socioculturel la composante
politique et la composante économique ou
liés au développement va y avoir
différentes car qui vont nous permettre
de comprendre ses composantes en tout
cas de décrire ses composantes et je
vais voir c'est ce qui a des liens entre
ces composantes plat et le phénomène que
j'avais décrit à l'étape du 10 où mon
élève corrélation n'est pas raison
il peut y avoir des corrélations mais
sans qu'il y ait finalement de lien de
causalité entre les deux pour savoir
s'il ya un lien de causalité de judo
passé à troisième étape de la démarche
géographie étape 3 la mobilisation de
certains modèles spatiaux ou même de
certains concepts mais il faut qu on
savoir que cette théorie là n'est pas le
but la géographie le but de géographie
c'est de comprendre la répartition mais
on est obligés de mobiliser cette
théorie là si vous voulez pour
finalement dire en effet qu'il ya bien
un lien si on peut résumer ici la
démarche graphique c'est très sain il ya
trois étapes la première jeu des cui des
répartitions d'un phénomène la deuxième
j'établis des liens entre cette
répartition et la répétition d'autres
composants et en troisième lieu je vais
mobiliser des modèles théoriques comme
par exemple tectonique des plaques
pour comprendre le lien entre la
répartition de mon phénomène de départ
et les différentes composantes que j'ai
pu trouver par la suite il la porte
d'entrée c'est pas forcément toujours la
répartition d'un phénomène
ça peut être la répartition de la
population ça peut être aussi un
aménagement qu'un pourquoi est ce que
dans cette région là on fait ça
finalement la démarche géographique
c'est toujours répondra aux trois mêmes
questions ou pourquoi là et pas ailleurs
mais ça je suppose que vous le saviez
déjà
je vous remercie pour votre attention
alors cette vidéo était prêt
incarnez puisque là j'ai vraiment été
très théorique mais je pense que c'est
une base importante finalement combien
faire la géographie parce que souvent
les élèves se rendent au cours de
géographie sans savoir ce qu'est faire
de la girafe il pense que c'est juste
étudier le monde des pays et des
capitales alors que finalement il ya
vraiment une démarche intellectuelle
intéressante qui va permettre à chacun
de développer les capacités que seul le
cours de géographie travail dans un
cursus secondaire pour préparer cet
exposé je me suis bien sûr inspiré du
programme du nouveau programme de
géographie de la formation géographie
une 3e 4e 5e 6e mais aussi du manuel
apprendre à lire le monde aux éditions
de bouc qui est déjà un peu datés mais
moi je trouve ça très intéressant et
notamment un super schéma qui vous
explique un petit peu la démarche
graphique et enfin si on veut un petit
peu entré dans le plus théorique
didactique de la géographie est toujours
aux éditions de bouc je vous remercie
pour votre attention je vous remercie
pour tous les gens qui m'ont que vous
avez à l'égard de cette chaîne et de ses
vidéos et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]